[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing what ruby's hagrid would see
in the mirror of erised the mirror of
erised is a magical mirror
that shows us the deepest most desperate
desires of our hearts
this is reflected in the mirror's name
no pun intended as error said flipped
around
reads as desire the mirror itself was
made sometime before the end of the 19th
century
and is located in the room of
requirement in hogwarts
but despite the existence of the mirror
and the emphasis placed on it in the
first novel
it strangely never really revealed what
many of the main characters would see
in the mirror we know harry sees his
parents ron sees himself as head boy
and dumbledore claims to see socks
though i suspect this to be untrue
even at this stage of his life but what
about other characters
what about hagrid i've got a few
theories for what hogwarts lovable
gamekeeper would see
so let's dive into it hagrid was born
rubius hagrid in the year 1928
to his father mr hagrid and his giantess
mother fred walther
hagrid gets his immense size from his
mother's side as hagrid's father was
just a regular sized man
his mother left him and his father while
he was still quite young returning to
the giant colony from which she came
this loved hagrid's father to raise him
alone my dad was broken-hearted when she
went
tiny little bloke my dad was by the time
i was six i could lift him up and put
him on top of the dresser if he annoyed
me
used to make him laugh very little is
known about hagrid's formative years
or parents but his father certainly
raised him well as in spite of his giant
size
hagrid was a caring attentive softy who
cared immensely for those that were
close to him
like other children hagrid began
attending hogwarts in the year 1940
before being sorted into gryffindor
house
hagrid was a promising young wizard but
did have a habit of getting into trouble
trouble which almost always stemmed or
pertained to magical creatures in some
way
however what would become hagrid's
biggest mistake was acquiring a new and
dangerous pet
an acromentula by the name of aragog
hagrid's issues began to arise when
students started to become mysteriously
petrified
on a consistent basis at the time no one
knew what was happening or why it was
happening
but it's later uncovered that it was in
fact tom riddle who had opened up the
chamber of secrets and released the
fabled basilisk within
naturally the school vehemently tried to
uncover the culprit for the
petrifications
and hagrid was eventually framed by
riddle explaining that they were the
actions of his pet aragog
hagrid never got much of a chance to
defend himself and was promptly expelled
this also meant that his wand was
snapped he was barred from magic
school didn't turn out exactly how
hagrid had wanted however he was allowed
to work as game
and live on the school grounds at the
request of albus dumbledore but despite
hagrid's troubled start
he never let his mood waver and grew
into an outstanding man with impeccable
morals
and a positive outlook on life however i
am of the impression that one of
hagrid's biggest regrets
was never graduating from hogwarts and
this is going to be the basis of my
theory
with regards to what he would actually
see in the mirror i think that if hagrid
were to look into the mirror he would
see himself
graduating from hogwarts with his proud
father mr hagrid by his side
hagrid's father tragically died while
hagrid was in his second year and still
a student
he died with the knowledge that hagrid
was pursuing top-notch magical education
and he was proud of him for it the only
thing that hagrid was thankful for
was that his dad never lived to see him
get expelled i think hagrid being able
to properly graduate alongside his peers
with his father watching on would be the
cherry on top of his life
on that note it's entirely possible that
graduating was never a big deal to him
and he would have preferred that his
father lived to see him become a proper
professor at school instead
which he eventually became that's my
first theory but
an alternate theory that i have is that
hagrid's life would be more or less the
same
i think that if hagrid looked into the
mirror he would see all of those that
were close to him huddled around
they'd be in his cottage on hogwarts
grounds though it would be slightly
bigger to accommodate everyone
and they'd be sitting around the fire
showing a laugh hagrid was first and
foremost a people person
and those that he cared about were the
most important elements of his life
and that's it for this video what do you
think hagrid would see
in the mirror of erised let me know in
the comment section below
until next time here's the last outro of
this year
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you